Continuing in this vein of wonder, we
have Robert-Houdin. This is the
gentleman who revealed the defecating
duck to be a fake. So he did many things.
Not only was he an incredible clock
maker and magician and also invented the
mystery clock, he actually was hired by
the French government to put down a
rebellion.
So his magic was so good they hired him
to go out and pretend to be a sorcerer,
and he basically saved France. So not
many clock makers can put that on their
CV. What's most interesting is the fact
that Robert-Houdin was the son of a
watchmaker, and had planned to be a
watchmaker, but actually went to law
school. And while he went to a book shop
to collect a two-volume set on law, he
was mistakenly given a two-volume set on
magic. And the world was never the same.
He ended up moving into Paris and
marrying the daughter of a prominent
clock maker. And his time there really
totally redid magic.
He's considered the father of modern
magic, and was the first magician to
incorporate mechanical devices and
clocks using electricity into his shows,
which was definitely a result of his
work as a clock maker. So not only did Houdin inspire a lot of firms to
actually go on and develop other mystery
clocks, but he also inspired the very
famous Russian goldsmith Peter Carl
Fabergé.
So, Fabergé was the goldsmith to the Czar,
Nicholas II, and took much of his
inspiration from master works of the
past. So this is his version of the
Houdin Orange Tree. This is known as the
Bay Tree Egg, this is from 1911. So
instead of having the handkerchief that
carries this piece with the butterflies,
it actually has a singing bird in the
center, which is also a homage to
Jaquet-Droz, who invented the Singing Bird.
Here is none other than his tiny Silver
Swan automaton. This actually came in
another one of his beautiful eggs.
He actually had 52 of these eggs that
were created by Faberge for the Czar
Nicholas II. He had a standing order of
two of these every year, so there was one
for his mother and one for his wife. This
beautiful egg has matte lilac enamel,
it has the swan that sits in a bed of
aquamarine with all these beautiful
little flowers. What's probably the most
surprising thing about this mechanical
swan is the fact that it is actually
made of gold and then plated in
silver. How's that for an Easter present?
And this is from the year 1906. When
Peter Carl took over his father's firm,
there was definitely this move from
producing jewelry to producing kind of
artist-jeweler type objects. So this
particular one was the Peacock Egg. Don't
know if I mentioned this, but his mother
got all of the mechanical ones, so this
was this beautiful peacock that
certainly had to have been influenced by
another older artwork. Since the Fabergé
firm was actually also the keepers of
the objects inside the Hermitage, they
looked after and repaired many of the
objects within the collection there. This
allowed Fabergé to go and study all of
these older pieces and build replicas and different pieces that would pay
homage to these master works of the past.